dans ce nouvel entrepôt sami a tout le
matériel nécessaire pour inspecter
soigneusement la marchandise des fruits
et légumes frais qu'il faut trier avant
la redistribution on était six pour
travailler autour d'une table maintenant
on a deux tables en travail et droit
par table et on travaille mieux ici la
banque alimentaire réparti les denrées
sur plus de 2500 m² c'est trois fois
plus que ce qu'elle possédait avant le
déménagement est plus de place ça veut
aussi dire plus de sécurité
nous avons beaucoup plus d espace
énormément plus d espace ce qui permet
de faire le tri dans un coin de décharge
et des camionnettes de l'autre et ça
nous permet donc côté sécurité d'assumer
beaucoup plus tout le fonctionnement du
fabrique une soixantaine de bénévoles
reçoivent vérifie pu répertorie les
provisions grâce à une telle surface
l'association à une plus grande chambre
froide deux tiers de la marchandise sont
des produits frais des vivres
supplémentaires qui augmente le besoin
demandeurs le nombre est illimitée des
bénévoles pour l'instant on n'envisage
pas de refuser le l'arrivée d'un
bénévole mais 5 10 15
il n'y a aucun souci on trouvera les
occuper puis ça peut éventuellement
permettre à un bénévole qui fait trois
quatre matins par semaine de n'en faire
que 2 ou 3 chaque année plus de 3000
tonnes de nourriture sont distribués par
la banque alimentaire de bourgogne soit
quatre millions et demi de repas